wow fascinating he goes c4
okay so he goes for in english
um
and we've talked about this before i
think the best way to quote-unquote
punish the english
punish being a very strong word
uh but but to
to play in a principled way is to go for
the reverse sicilian to go on to go c45
[Music]
and
against the immediate g3
black has
a tremendous amount of good setups uh
setups setups
and you can play this exactly as you
would play an open sicilian with white
you could play knight f6 bishop g2 d5
you could play an allopin you could play
c6 here which is a move that i played
before
but if you really want to take it to
your opponent you could even go h5
the move h5 i've played before in sirius
blitz games you're essentially trying to
immediately exploit the hook on g3
in this game
uh i want to play something between
knight f6 and h5 so let's play c6 let's
play an elephant style structure and see
what happens c6
so
this is a very annoying one now
obviously we're going to play d5 here
takes takes
and we already have a very nice position
he didn't really do a good job
contesting our center okay so he's
that's what he's trying to do now but
he's doing it
sort of with the wrong pieces queen to
b3 is not a very dangerous move
what should we do about this pawn how
should we defend it
should we go bishop e6 perhaps
how should we go about
defending the pawn on d5 which is being
attacked of course by two pieces
and then knight f6 of course knight f6
is the simplest
yeah knight f6
time to defend the pawn
all right so now um we need to be
careful
and
we need to be creative
so um
this is
an important moment in the game because
a lot of you are thinking about bishop
b6 but if you extend the calculation
huntress i'm going to time you out
um
if you think about bishop b6 what
happens there
uh what happens after we play bishop e6
yeah so he plays queen takes b7
and a lot of people would stop
calculating at that precise moment but
what if you don't stop calculating what
if you extend that calculation for one
more move bishop b6 queen takes b7
remember that he's not developed his
king side and when the queen is stuck on
b7 like this
that's um
a you know potentially very good
sacrifice
so what happens after bishop e6 queen
takes b7 can we salvage the rook on a8
yeah we can play knight bd7
and what you're going to see
is that he's going to have a very hard
time untangling his pieces knight p to
d7 he could even take another pawn and
if he does that which i think he will
um
we'll figure out what to do but these
kinds of very practical approaches uh
can lead to very quick wins
okay so we need to figure out what the
weak points are in white's position now
clearly there is something on d5 which
we could try to exploit
first of all we need to figure out
whether we want to take on d5 and if so
with what piece
and we need to be um
you know we need to be aware
of both bishop takes d5 and knight takes
d5 both moves may make sense
okay so let's start with the simplest
move if we play knight takes d5 he plays
bishop takes d5 and notice how in that
position
the bishop is making contact with
white's bishop what what is defending
white's bishop well it's the queen
well there's a good reason that we lured
the queen onto b7 it's because it's very
easy to attack
so after 95 bishop d5
what natural move comes to mind and i
think we're going to win a piece in that
precise way
just play not knight b6 but rook b8 to
dislodge the queen from b7 that's all
there is to a knight takes d5 this is
very easy
straightforward calculation
because the moves are so natural rook b8
attacked the queen
the queen basically has to drop back to
c6
and then we need to be careful for one
more move
because
i think a lot of you might be attracted
to rook to b6
but if you look a little bit more
carefully you'll notice that the queen
will have the c4 square and white
successfully evacuates
in one piece
okay so what should you do instead
yeah rook c8 of course rook c8
and rook c8 queen b5 and then rook c5
will fork the queen and the bishop
rook c8
you can also go queen b7 and then we'll
play rook c7
so what basically wherever the queen
goes we chase the queen away
uh this is all very simple and this
shows you actually i think this is a
very good illustration of why the queen
is such a bad defender the queen is very
bad at defending other pieces because
it's so easy to attack the queen when
you attack the queen it must respond to
the attack
and it must essentially abandon the
pieces that it was previously defending
okay so the game is basically over he's
got to move the queen
then he drops this bishop and
that's a very bad bishop to lose
he can't even get a third pawn for it by
the way
yeah queen d3 bishop d5 queen d3 bishop
takes d5 and he's down in bishop or rook
takes d5 doesn't really matter
what about queen b7
well then we just take on d5 anyway
yeah rook forks can look very awkward
but they're very effective
rook forks
are among the easiest to miss there is
something awkward about forking with a
rook
but it's it's just something you should
be watchful of
oh queen b7 will well technically he
does but queen b7 bishop takes d5 and
then we take the rook but yes
technically he gets the third pawn for
it
yeah he's thinking here but obviously
the game is essentially over
okay
so
the mistake for white
well i'll show you what his mistakes
were but he didn't play well in the
opening
and then of course he shouldn't have
i mean i honestly think that he probably
can get away with this if he plays
very precisely but i i i really don't
think he should have done that
practically speaking he was two pawn
hungry this is a classic example
in the dangers upon grabbing
okay so let's finish the game
obviously as with any other position the
priority should be on development
some of you may be thinking about taking
this knight on f3 just to simplify
but i don't think that's a great idea
because we literally have an uncontested
light squirt bishop
and he's uh he's got a ruined fianchetto
structure so
i would keep this bishop in the event
that we get
some sort of mating ideas down this long
diagonal when the knight leaves f3
so there's no need for anything creative
here
i wouldn't even bother with queen c7
because then he can castle and
simultaneously defend the bishop
so instead i would prioritize the
development of my bishop
i don't even care about the spawn let
him take it
let him take the spawn because we're
going to completely overwhelm him in the
center and on the king side
it's going to be crushing
it's going gonna be tremendous
it's gonna be amazing
um
it's gonna be the best attack anybody's
ever seen before
yeah we're just gonna castle
and then we're gonna
we're gonna crush him
so
yeah this is um
this is pretty simple
okay
sorry i'm pretty exhausted so b4
now where should we put the rook
what seems to be the most active square
well uh we can bring it back to c8
there's nothing wrong with that
but
i particularly like
the idea of going rook c4
sliding the rook into c4
attacking before pinning the pawn this
seems like game over basically
okay now we can just castle
oh everything was winning i mean
this is simply a matter of completing
your development and
you know just getting down to the
business of finishing them off
e5 was fine but
in these kinds of positions when you're
working on your technique you want to
focus on getting the bare bones
the bare bones stuff down
can you finish your development
can you make sure that you're not
dropping any pawns or pieces
unnecessarily
when you do that you can focus then on
fit you know on finessing stuff and
getting the fancy stuff down
well queen a would have dropped the
knight on d7 i don't want to i don't
want to drop that knight
yeah we definitely want to push e4
if given the opportunity for sure okay
so
oh gosh i'm like
oh okay so we have a beautiful win
though
we have a beautiful winning idea now how
did i find this idea
well
let me walk you through it
one sec
the first thing that i see here
is uh the pin that the rook exerts on
the pawn
okay the pawn on b4 right so this pawn
is immobilized everybody should see that
so what moves stem naturally from this
pin
well some of you guys indicated a5
but there is also the move knight to c5
now knight to c5 doesn't seem to
accomplish anything because he can just
drop the bishop drop the queen back but
these are the kinds of ideas
kind of like a lego set where you can
build off of them
you can take this idea of knight c5 you
can transform it via
some other preliminary transformation
and you can get it to work
so knight c5 doesn't do anything
but i'm noticing the square on d3
if the knight can potentially get to d3
that would be a fork on the on the king
of the bishop
so
in your mind you should be saying well
what's stopping the knight from getting
to d3 well obviously it's the e2 pawn
but we've got a piece uh we've got just
the piece with which we can distract the
spawn and get it to move we can take on
f3 first
then go knight c5 and knight has a free
passageway to d3
and white doesn't even have a way of
defending the b2 bishop with this queen
white either has to go forward with this
queen
and then we take on v2 and
simultaneously defend the rook on c4 or
he drops the queen back to d1 and then
loses the bishop anyway
brutal idea
yeah that's a nice one
you can also go knight c5 first you can
go knight c5 first but it's a tiny bit
more complicated he's got queen b5 and
stuff
yeah
good stuff here
queen b5 plane so we throw in a check
and that's a very important detail but
this is not a side detail this is
crucial the knight on b2 defends the
rook on c4 and now here's the amazing
thing i think this is what makes this so
elegant
now the rolls begin to be switched now
the knight's like all right rook i'm in
trouble
i'm on b2 i have no squares i'm in
trouble i need you to step up to the
plate and now the rook steps in to
defend the knight
so they're sharing responsibilities
essentially
okay
so rook c1 you got to be very careful
um
if you just passively take
you are still at risk of getting your
night trapped in the end
so what should black play here what's
the most accurate move the most accurate
move is to involve the queen
basically resolve the tension in your
favor you're trying to get white to take
so you can take with the queen and then
the queen steps in and then that's
basically game over white's initiative
fizzles out
white's initiative fizzles out there
takes takes
queen c8 is fine too doesn't matter
queen c8 is just as good it's the same
thing
very wholesome stuff yeah so if i were
you and you know
if you're 1400 or 1500 i would play
queen c4 check and trade the queens
that's what i'm going to do
um
you know i've read on on reddit i think
so okay that's not what i'm going to do
he's going to resign
i think i'm going to make a slightly
bigger effort to play
in more simple style when i'm winning
just to illustrate practical technique i
think sometimes
uh and this is i think a legitimate
piece of constructive criticism that i
noticed in
the subreddit you know the writer
discussion which is that
at times
and i think this was brought to the
table very respectfully i'm
incorporating it
i can get bugs bogged down with like
quote-unquote beautiful ideas or
you know winning ideas that are not
necessarily
practical uh so i'm going to try to make
more of a focus on
you know on on
technique that's that's more practical
and more applicable
um so i'm going to do my best to
incorporate that as well
um
when you know when we're when we're
winning and when i'm when i'm showing
technique and stuff
that's not to say i'm going to like
you know perform brain surgery on my
actual ideas this is just narrowly
focused on when i'm totally winning and
stuff
so c45 g3
okay so we decided on the alpine the
reverse allopin
um
which is a great line i think this is
one of the best lines against the
english
and by the way
that's why a lot of people like to start
with knight c3
uh because if you try to play c6 here
well that's just not as effective
because the knights already contesting
the d5 square
so after something like d4
you get a reverse elephant but a tempo
down
and you're not able to get d5 in
and that's just kind of sag so after g3
you get more of an opportunity to get d5
in
all right so
d4
um
d4 i mean it's good to be picky that's
that's what i ask of people
yeah so d4 i think is the main line just
like it is in uh on the black side of
the elephant d4 takes takes
um
takes takes d5
and um i'm not sure how the theory
continues here
i think it's something like bishop g2
uh knight f6
knight c3 and
again
you know black is playing the allopin
down at tempo so
it's not quite as good as it is from the
white side but it's something you could
definitely consider i think black is
supposed to equalize here quite
comfortably
um so in any case bishop g2 kind of lets
me do what i want d5
cdcd
and now queen b3 is a weird move he's
he's basically recruiting his queen to
do a job
which his knight could have done so he's
basically forsaking his development
now if i were white here i would just
play d3
and then i would just get my knight out
to f3 i would play it almost like a perk
and clearly black is a great position
knight c6
you know we could even begin with h6 we
could even play h6 to preemptively cover
the bishop from coming to g5
castles knight f6
black's got a super comfortable position
but white is white is solid here white
is not losing or anything of that sort
um
yeah thanks pikachu what time is it it's
12 48 but i'm i'm about to hit the sack
guys i'm pretty exhausted
um
yeah my goal is to help people
organically develop the ability to have
that thought process
okay
so queen b3
knight f6
um knight c3
and now bishop e6 the most important
move of the whole game
this is um
the most important move and i'll explain
why in a second
what are the arguments for black having
a better position in the previous
version
well um
i would say that
first of all the central control i mean
you've got both pawns in the center and
they're very well protected by the
knights basically you've got ideal
development like you've got all of your
pieces developed
uh once you get your bishops out to the
squares that you want to develop them to
you've got more space you've got the
center it's just a slight advantage
don't overthink it that's that's not
i'm not claiming that black is like
winning or anywhere near
being even even being much better it's
it's more mostly the center that's
that's
the source of black's advantage
all right so
bishop e6 now
obviously this appears to blunder the
pawn
but
we realize we see the bigger picture
here this is something which
i think if you're at 1700 it's one of
the things which you
should be focusing on learning how to do
better
it's also not something which is really
trainable that easily it's not something
i've seen discussed too many times in
books
and i would almost call this seeing the
bigger picture that's literally what i
would call this concept
and it's a concept that
a lot of things
uh fall under the umbrella of this
concept
and one of them is this ability to
not reject moves
which appear to be bad for some very
straightforward reason such as the fact
that they blunder upon
or
even such as the fact that they may
may appear to be passive or they may
appear to
to create a weakness or something like
that there's a lot of moves like that
which if you're 14 1500 you tend to
reject super quickly because they
just look bad but when you cross a
certain threshold if you want to build
up your creativity i think that's what
creativity is it's the ability to
consider moves that may seem bad
and then to give them a chance
and out of every 10 moves like that that
you consider maybe two or three of them
are going to end up working
so you've just got to calculate a few
moves ahead here
um
and you're helped along by the fact that
you still have control of the center
white still hasn't developed his king
side and white's queen is clearly in
trouble so those are the intuitive
considerations that lead me to believe
the black is going to be much better
here despite being down upon
the only thing that you have to
calculate here is knight takes d5
because
if
white is able to get away with this
then you will be down two pawns and
that's a little bit too many pawns to
give up just for some sort of positional
compensation
and this is what i had to calculate
and how do we calculate this well we
need to figure out what's wrong with
this move
and if we get to this position the rest
of the calculation is quite simple i
know this sounds weird
you know it sounds like i'm
oversimplifying it but i honestly think
that if you just look at this position
logically
you should notice the two main drawbacks
of white setup
number one the bishops are at a standoff
number two you could think of this also
as a type two undefended piece
and um sorry type one undefended piece
and the second thing is that the queen
is the piece that is protecting the
bishop so the queen is the most
vulnerable piece on the chessboard
um and that helps you uh determine that
you can chase the queen around until
it's forced to lose contact with the
bishop
so rook b8
um
what about queen b7 rook c7 queen a8
okay what if he didn't take the pawn on
d5 yeah so first of all
what would have happened if he didn't
take the pawn on d5
well
um what could he have done instead
if he would have played and this is
going to be this is going to blow your
mind
if he would have played a move like d3
right just trying to develop his bishop
black to play and win this is an amazing
uh queen trap
this is a this is a pattern which i
recommend people to like write down or
just really internalize because it will
come up in your games
it's a trap that
uniquely is connected with the placement
of the knight on d7
let's see yeah so knight c5 is the moon
knight c5 is the move very good
and um the nail in the coffin is that
after queen c6 bishop d7 the screen is
trapped literally check it yourself the
queen is trapped
but okay why can go queen b5 check right
no still bishop d7 and the queen is
still trapped
because after queen b4 um of course
there is the discover check on d3
winning the queen
yeah this is very cool
so
white literally is at risk of losing his
queen
knight f3 doesn't help knight c5 it's
the same exact pattern
so in order to evacuate his queen white
would have had to have been proactive in
in moving the queen away to b5 which is
not something which is easy to see
thank you villatelli for the tier one
all right
so queen b5 i think would have been the
best option for white
and then you could basically try to use
the queen
to uh
to make improvements to your position
you just need to rook a b8
queen a4 and then maybe d4
and the bottom line is you can see the
kind of initiative the black has in this
position black is just
pushing the pawns into the center
white is still not developed on the king
side and and this is just
a phenomenal position for black
um
so that's basically that uh and that's
the compensation that we have for the
queen for the pawn
now he ends up taking on d5
take take rook b8 queen c6 rock c8 again
be very careful in these positions when
you're chasing the queen away
move like rook b6 is very tempting
but you've got to make sure that you
have the line calculated until the end
and if you go rook before here and you
keep trying to chase the queen away
in addition to playing queen c6 which
basically leads to a three-time
repetition
can anybody spot the other option that
white has in this position which yields
i think a decent position for white
and this is another point i wanted to
make
as i was pursuing his queen
so queen c6 is one option
the other option is to play bishop take
c6
and wait a second you might say
this loses the queen
um and it does but
remember what and i would call this
something like the queen's syndrome it's
like
people often assume that whenever you
win the queen for any amount of material
it's going to be good for the side of
the queen because there's an almost
emotional element of being up a queen
i'm sure everybody can relate to this
and i'll show you an example where i did
this
uh and i learned from this game
but always remember to check
um
how much material your opponent has for
the queen like in this case you've got a
rook
a bishop and and two pawns and that's
plenty of material for the queen the
position probably is approximately equal
uh and
white's got a phenomenal position here
so
be very careful
and make sure that you're not blinded by
the fact that you're winning the queen
and you're not giving up an obscene
amount of material for it
i have a great um
i have a great example of when i did
literally that
that exact thing
and i i learned a very valuable lesson
from this game
okay
i uh was playing white
as you can see with
larry snyder who was a
you know uh
you know was like two local 2000 from
san francisco
and this was a scandy as
you can probably determine
and i had sacrificed the pawn on b2 as
you can also probably determine
and in this position i started thinking
and i found
what i thought was an absolutely
brilliant idea
obviously if if i just play this
casually if i just play a move like
queen f3
if if i just improve my position
the compensation that white has for the
pawn is immense and look at how active
my pieces are
but
um i was like no no no i'm not doing
that
i'm going to go knight to b5
okay so he takes
bishop takes b5 check he covers the
check
and now the whole point of the sacrifice
is to clear out to vacate the c4 square
what's going to go on the square it's
going to be the knight knight c4 is what
i played
okay so the queen can't go back to d6
it has to take on a2
and now the conclusion to my amazing
idea
rook a1 and uh the queen is trapped you
know the queen is trapped
and i did see
that he could take on a1
uh but i had calculated this and i had
determined that white has what very
important intermediate move here you
don't want to take the queen
you want to do what
you want to play bishop takes d7 check
knight b takes d7 and just queen takes
a1 and white has a queen for a rook and
a piece now this is good for white
what had i missed in this position but i
didn't really
take this seriously i had really stopped
calculating here but you can play bishop
takes b5
rook takes a2 bishop takes c4
and all of a sudden i'm like oh my
goodness
he's
got three pieces
and a pawn for the queen
he's got total domination over the
central squares
he's got a past a pawn which is going to
decide the game
and he has the potential of taking one
of my rooks if he wants
and he ends up not even having to take
my rook he literally keeps the bishop on
the board because he determines that
this bishop on c4 is so nice
that he doesn't even need to take my
rook
he literally just basically pushes the
paw i mean he defends nicely
and he pushes the pawn all the way to a2
and then he wins another exchange and
then it takes another pawn
and i literally resigned here because
he's just overwhelming with overwhelming
me with material
and this taught me a very important
lesson
uh in
you know
in um
not
getting fixated on the concept of just
winning a queen but understanding that
this needs to be put into its proper
context you can have a lot of material
for the queen it can be too much stuff
for the queen
uh and from that time i was
you know i was a lot less hesitant about
sacrificing my queen for you know rook
and two pieces for example
and i just became more attentive of that
uh so that's a little bit of a mini
lesson for you guys there
um
in in in that realm
it's funny because when i signed my
opponent's scoresheet he was like
um i'm going to sell this on ebay when
he becomes a gm like i think he
whispered it to my dad or something
uh and i like overheard it because he
was you know i'd known him for for many
years he used to play in uh my local
chess club and i kind of rolled my eyes
and i was like yeah he's only saying
that because he beat me
um i'm never gonna become gm
it's funny like looking at this game now
i i should find that score sheet that
would be pretty funny
uh he's probably
he's probably still alive he was
probably in his 50s late 50s when this
game was played
um
but in any case that's a little bit of a
lesson
on that
okay
so
let's go back to the game that's why you
want to play rook c8 you want to be
super
um careful about those kinds of things
so rook c8 is the key move
he sold it on ebay for 900 yes exactly
queen to b5 and rook to c5 wins the game
now
he can't give up his queen here for
anything more than a rook and that's the
difference like he can take the rook but
that's going to be it he's not going to
get another minor piece for the queen
uh
and that's it he was born in 1942 okay
he's older than i thought
he looked good for his age i think he's
a doctor
so
by the way the last thing
if he plays queen to b7
should we go rook b8 or should we go
rook c7
and i just noticed something quite
amazing here
um
it was a little miscalculation that
happened
so after rook c7
um
i had miscalculated something white has
an incredible resource in this position
queen a8
he's got queen a8
and amazingly i think white is emerging
from this alive
so let me think
you can go back to c8 white repeats
moves with queen b7
yeah someone posted this earlier nice
yeah so this amazingly
leads to white's survival queen queen
queen queen b7 queen a8 now i wouldn't
have repeated moves if this had happened
probably um
well rook ba we talked about rook b8
queen c6
and if you play knight c5
you open up
this diagonal so for example white could
even give bishop c6 check
and you have to essentially cover the
check and offer a trade which is
desirable for white
um
but i think this would have led to a
drop
which is quite amazing so
maybe somewhere earlier on
i had made a mistake let me see
let me just calculate for a second
yeah i i think that
once this all happens this is all forced
takes takes takes think this all seems
very forced
um
and if i was playing uh if he had played
this
i would have probably just gotten my
bishop out i mean i would have gone for
the win
and i would have gone for something like
this and then just tried to attack down
the f file
but i'm not going to pretend that this
is like objectively sound at this point
i think black doesn't have enough for
the two pawns we're just basically
playing playing hope chess
um
so i suppose
what that tells us is that from a purely
objective standpoint bishop e6 might not
have been the best move
and perhaps d4 should have been
preferred
um
but that's
pretty coincidental and i i'm not i
don't regret playing bishop e6 i think
it's still the right move
from a practical standpoint
um it's just that sometimes it turns out
that you do everything right
and there's some crazy resource at the
end that saves the game
and then you just have no choice but to
tip your hat to your opponent
all right
so
other than that i think the rest was
simple i mean we take the bishop we
develop our other bishop we bring our
rook to c4 and then the final
uh nail in the coffin
uh it comes from this combination we
take the knight
to
divert this pawn from e2
the key is that the d3 square is now a
weakness
knight c5
knight d3 and ip2 well it's it's not up
to me whether people can visit the
charlotte classic
anybody can visit a tournament
i'm not
i
i don't decide whether spectators can
visit your everybody's welcome to visit
if you're in the if you're in the area
knight c5 and this is a good game
because
no matter where he goes with the queen
he cannot defend the d3 square
um
and that's
about it
who was the player who beat you with
your ill-fated queen trove his name is
larry snyder um thank you for the five i
appreciate it i'm going to call it a
night i'm absolutely exhausted
um today was a great day of trust though
have a great night take care everybody
thanks for the support
and uh we'll see you guys soon bye
[Music]